[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg willkommen und guten
Abend ihnen allen an meiner Seite ist
wieder Norbert Lehmann für den
Sportplatz
Kampf gegen rekordinflation die
Europäische Zentralbank erhöht den
Leitzins und zwar kräftig schön für
Sparer schlecht für Bauherren
Entlastung für Gas und Fernwärmekunden
der Bund will im Dezember die
Abschlagszahlungen übernehmen und damit
die Zeit bis zur Einführung der
gaspreisbremse überbrücken
und Haftstrafe für Alfons Schuhbeck der
Star Koch muss wegen Steuerhinterziehung
für drei Jahre und zwei Monate ins
Gefängnis
[Musik]
wir merken es alle die Preise in der
Eurozone steigen derzeit so schnell wie
nie in der Geschichte der Währungsunion
im September lag die Inflation bei
9,9%. mit einer kräftigen Zinserhöhung
versucht die Europäische Zentralbank
gegenzusteuern nach langem Zögern hatte
sie im Juli den Leitzins erhöht erstmals
seit elf Jahren im September legte sie
nach und heute nochmal auf zwei Prozent
Markus wollsziffer
vorbei das zögerliche agieren ezb-chefin
lagar demonstriert Entschlossenheit
heute in Frankfurt zum zweiten Mal in
Folge + 0,75% Punkte der Leitzins zu dem
sich Geschäftsbanken bei der EZB
frisches Geld leihen klettert damit auf
zwei Prozent die Idee der Währungshüter
Kredite verteuern um die Nachfrage zu
bremsen und damit die hohen
Teuerungsraten einzudämmen
die Inflation ist nach wie vor deutlich
zu hoch und wird für längere Zeit über
dem Zielwert bleiben
viele Experten und Branchen halten die
Entscheidung für längst überfällig die
Baubranche zum Beispiel die mit
explodierenden Material und
Energiepreisen zu kämpfen hat viele
Aufträge brechen weg das Ifo-Institut
spricht mittlerweile von einer
stornierungswelle das Problem ein
höherer Leitzins bekämpft zwar die
Inflation lässt aber gleichzeitig die
Hypothekenzinsen steigen der Traum vom
Eigenheim für viele damit unbezahlbar
wenn sie in Kreditvolumen haben von
500.000 Euro und hatten das mit ein
Prozent und zwei Prozent Tilgung waren
sie bei einer Rate von um die 13 1400
Euro auf heutigen Zinsniveau bedeutet
das 2500 Euro und das ist natürlich eine
Steigerung ja die viele Familien so gar
nicht verkraften können immerhin für
Sparer hat der Zinsschritt positive
Auswirkungen es gibt wieder Zinsen
manche Banken werden bereits damit
es lohnt sich wieder sich um zu gucken
und zwischen Banken zu vergleichen weil
wenn die eine Bank schon drei Prozent
für drei Jahre Zeit und die andere Bank
immer noch kein vernünftiges Festgeld
anbietet dann ist das ein riesen
Unterschied die EZB hat bereits
angekündigt es werde vermutlich nicht
die letzte Zinserhöhung sein allen
rezessionsrisiken zum Trotz
fragen wir Frank Bethmann an der Börse
in Frankfurt wann ist damit zu rechnen
dass die Preise nicht mehr so stark
steigen
naja was das ambelangente wird der
Winter noch eisig bleiben frühestens im
Frühjahr dann könnte der Höhepunkt bei
der Teuerung erreicht sein es braucht
Zeit bis Leitzinserhöhungen wirken
manchmal dauert es Wochen oder sogar
Monate Zeit die jetzt für viele
schmerzhaft ist Zeit aber auch die zuvor
von der EZB nicht genutzt wurde so spät
hat sie angefangen den Kampf gegen die
Teuerung aufzunehmen und so bleibt der
Preisdruck über die Wintermonate sehr
wahrscheinlich hoch so hoch dass ich die
Notenbank inzwischen einem anderen
Problem gegenübersieht nämlich dass sie
Vertrauen verloren hat denn einer
Umfrage zufolge glauben inzwischen viele
Bürger dass Europa noch länger mit
höheren Preisen zu kämpfen hat also der
Glaube dass die Europäische Zentralbank
zumindest schnell wieder für stabile
Preise sorgen kann der ist beschädigt
und so ist dieser zweite große
Zinsschritt hintereinander heute auch
als zu verstehen als Signal der
Währungshüter wir kriegen das wieder hin
danke für diese Einschätzung aus
Frankfurt Frank Bethmann
eine bemerkenswerte Begleiterscheinung
der hohen Inflation der Staat verdient
mit an den steigenden Preisen die
Steuereinnahmen gehen nach oben und zwar
kräftig die steuerschätze erwarten für
die kommenden Jahre
Rekordeinnahmen ihre Schätzungen sind
allerdings geprägt von hoher
Unsicherheit warnt der Finanzminister
Winnie Häscher hat mehr
die Preise sind hoch das Spüren alle im
Alltag der Staat aber profitiert von der
Inflation und von einem robusten
Arbeitsmarkt Lohn und Einkommensteuer
landen wie die Mehrwertsteuer in der
Staatskasse der Finanzminister aber
warnt die Krise sei groß Staat
BürgerInnen und Unternehmen bräuchten
dieses Geld dies ist und das bleibt auch
angesichts der massiv gestiegenen
Energiepreise richtig und wichtig
vermeintliche finanzielle Spielräume für
neue Vorhaben bestehen deshalb nicht in
diesem Jahr werden Steuereinnahmen von
knapp 888 Milliarden Euro erwartet
weniger als vorhergesagt ab nächstem
Jahr soll sich das Umkehren Einnahmen
von mehr als 937 Milliarden Euro bis
2026 wird mit mehr Einnahmen von
insgesamt 126 Milliarden Euro gerechnet
Christian Lindner dürfte wesentlich
höhere Schulden machen will er aber
nicht was breit kritisiert wird
bewegt wir brauchen nicht dass pseudo
Festhalten an einer Schuldenbremse
was jetzt durch künstliche Operationen
erreicht wird indem man riesige
Schuldenberge auf Vorrat aufnimmt nur um
dann im nächsten Jahr sagen zu können
die Schuldenbremse hält man ein wir
durchleben als Gesellschaft eine
existenzielle Krise für viele Menschen
für das Handwerk für kleine
mittelständische Unternehmen und es
braucht jetzt natürlich gezielte
Investitionen um aus dieser Krise
rauszukommen das heißt die
Schuldenbremse muss endlich fallen in
einem sind sich alle einig mit Lindner
diese Steuerschätzung ist unsicher wie
selten durch Pandemie Krieg und
Energiekrise
Milliarden landen aber auch wieder beim
Bürger heute hat das
Wirtschaftsministerium einen Entwurf für
eine Soforthilfe vorgelegt Gas- und
Fernwärmekunden sollen im Dezember
nichts zahlen müssen das hatte eine
Expertenkommission vorgeschlagen wie das
funktionieren soll zeigt Gluten leinhaus
es klingt einfach den dezemberabschlag
zahlt der Staat eher überweist das Geld
den Energieversorgern und die geben die
Erstattung umgehend an uns Verbraucher
weiter für ein familienhausbesitzer und
für Mieter mit Gasetagenheizung könnte
das so klappen sie haben einen direkten
Vertrag mit ihrem Versorger geplant ist
die Abschlagszahlung für Dezember
einmalig auszusetzen
komplizierter ist bei
Wohnungseigentümern oder Mietern die an
einer Gaszentralheizung hängen oder am
Fernwärmenetz hier erstatten die
Versorger pauschal an Vermieter oder
Hausverwaltung die ermitteln dann den
Anspruch für jede einzelne Wohnung das
kann bis zur nächsten
Nebenkostenabrechnung dauern sagen
vermieterverbände die Höhe der
Entlastung errechnet sich aus dem
gültigen dezembertarif des Versorgers
sowie einem Zwölftel des bisherigen
Jahresverbrauchs
jetzt könnte man ja denken diese
Unterstützung braucht es vielleicht gar
nicht mehr weil der
großhandelsgaspreis nach den Höhenflügen
der letzten Monate endlich wieder sinkt
so einfach ist das leider nicht Sven
Regen
199 Euro Abschlag im Monat zahlte
Hermann Rosenkranz aus Bad Schlema in
Sachsen mal für Erdgas dann kam der
Schock
1146 Euro sollte er plötzlich zahlen
monatlich und das bei einer Rente von
1800 Euro
ich dachte es wäre ein Schreibfehler
oder eine verarsche oder sowas
das kann ja kann ja kein Mensch bezahlen
jeden Monat 1 46 mehr auf bleibt ja
nichts wahrer übrig dabei fällt der
Gaspreis zur Zeit Grund die gefüllten
Gasspeicher Großkunde Deutschland kauft
nicht mehr die Nachfrage ist auf einen
Schlag geringer mildes Herbstwetter
lässt zudem Blätter und Gaspreise
purzeln das ändert aber nichts an der
börsenlogik die Versorger decken sich
mit Termingeschäften ein also
langfristigen Verträgen die täglich
schwankenden Preise entstehen aber am
sogenannten Spotmarkt der für die
Gasversorger zusprunghaft ist sprich
unkalkulierbar die Unternehmen kaufen
also langfristig und zur Zeit damit
teurer ein letztendlich bedeutet das
auch dass sie bei fallenden Gaspreisen
davon auch nicht profitieren können
insofern haben sie auch nicht
kurzfristig was weiterzugeben an die
Endkonsumenten kauft ein Gasversorger
aber gerade jetzt langfristig ein kann
es für Sekunden günstiger werden das
Registrieren auch die Vergleichsportale
gleichzeitig beobachten wir es die neue
kundenpreise also die die für
wechselkundenrelevant sind tatsächlich
deutlich gesunken sind im Vergleich zu
Anfang September haben die sich halbiert
also für zumindest für neue Kunden gibt
es ein bisschen Hoffnung Hermann
Rosenkranz wechselt jetzt zu seinem
günstigeren Grundversorger und er
reduziert seine Abschlagszahlung denn
auch das ist wichtig abgerechnet wird
meist nach einem Belieferungsjahr der
Abschlag ist also auch nur eine
Momentaufnahme
russlands Präsident Putin hat erneut den
Westen für die Zuspitzung der Lage in
der Ukraine verantwortlich gemacht in
einer Rede vor internationalen
Politikexperten sagte er frühe oder
später werde der Westen aber mit
Russland über eine gemeinsame Zukunft
sprechen müssen und Moskau habe nicht
die Absicht in der Ukraine Atomwaffen
einzusetzen
wie kann der Ukraine geholfen werden
darum ging es auch beim Besuch von
Bundeskanzler Scholz in Griechenland
konkret um militärische Hilfe Stichwort
Ringtausch Deutschland hat Athen
Schützenpanzer vom Typ Marder geliefert
dafür gaben die Griechen der Ukraine
Panzer sowjetischer Bau hat vor allem
aber das griechisch-türkische Verhältnis
spielte bei den Besuch eine Rolle
Andreas Kühnast
es gibt in Athen nur einen Ort der für
sich selbst spricht an dem Olaf Scholz
nicht sprechen muss und trotzdem
verstanden wird Kanzler auf Akropolis
Kanzler neben Ministerpräsident
Deutschland an der Seite von
Griechenland so ernst so massiv sind die
Spannungen zwischen Griechenland und der
Türkei das premier mit sotakis seit
Monaten um jede erdenkliche politische
Hilfe bittet es geht um das griechische
Militär auf den griechischen
Mittelmeerinseln die Türkei verlangt
seinen Abzug droht andernfalls mit
Invasion
unsere Nachbarn wissen es alle wissen es
die griechischen Inseln sind keine
Gefahr wir sind keine Gefahr
dann bereitet der Grieche den deutschen
auf Ärger vor auf eine heftige
Nebenwirkung des vereinbarten
ringtauschs diese sechs deutschen
Schützenpanzer vom Typ Marder vor
wenigen Tagen geliefert werden in
wenigen Tagen an die türkische Grenze
verlegt für Scholz eine rein griechische
Entscheidung wir haben wenn ich das
zunächst sagen darf die
Marder geliefert an Griechenland und da
gibt es keine tägliche Meldung wo die
gerade stehen wir fragen auch nicht nach
dabei ahnt man auch in der deutschen
Delegation dass das die Türkei
vermutlich anders sieht spätestens jetzt
ist der Streit zwischen Griechenland und
der Türkei auch ein deutsches Problem
Kanzler Scholz hat sich zwar heute auf
die Seite von Griechenland gestellt aber
so vorsichtig diplomatisch dass eine
deutsche Vermittlerrolle weiterhin
möglich ist
offiziell befinden sich Israel und der
Libanon immer noch im Krieg trotzdem
haben sie sich jetzt in einem Abkommen
über ihre Seegrenze geeinigt
jahrzehntelang hatten sie um das hier
markierte Gebiet im Mittelmeer
gestritten auch weil darin zwei
Gasfelder liegen nach Vermittlung durch
die USA ist der Zugang nun geregelt was
das für die Beziehung zwischen den
beiden Ländern bedeutet zeigt Michael
Beverungen
normalerweise wird ein wichtiger Vertrag
ja mit viel Brimborium und
Händeschütteln öffentlichkeitswirksam
gefeiert doch das Abkommen über die neue
Seegrenze unterschreibt israels
Ministerpräsident in Jerusalem still für
sich
auch im Libanon keine große Zeremonie
kein Wunder beide Länder befinden sich
offiziell noch immer im Kriegszustand
umso bedeutender dieser
Vertragsabschluss nach jahrelangen
Verhandlungen
das ist ein Erfolg nicht jeden Tag
erkennt ein feindliches Land Israel in
einem unterschriebenen Vertrag vor der
Weltöffentlichkeit an
genau deshalb ist der Vertrag ihm
Libanon umstritten keine Anerkennung
Israels aber dennoch Zustimmung zum
Vertrag signalisiert die Pro iranische
Hess Boller Miliz Lob aus den USA die
den Vertrag vermittelt haben und
Vorteile für beide Seiten sehen dieses
Abkommen erschließt Energiefelder in
beiden Ländern es bringt ihm
libanesischen Volk neue Hoffnungen
wirtschaftliche Möglichkeiten und
verbessert die Stabilität und Sicherheit
des israelischen Volkes
tatsächlich macht die Anerkennung der
Seegrenze beide Länder zu gewinnen sie
können nun mit der Ausbeutung großer
Gasvorkommen im umstrittenen Gebiet
beginnen auch in Europa und Deutschland
wecken die neuen Gasfelder
Begehrlichkeiten zwar ist die Lieferung
von Flüssiggas noch Zukunftsmusik und
die Gesamtmenge eher klein grundsätzlich
aber das wurde Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck bei seinem letzten Besuch
signalisiert kann sich Israel einen
solchen gas-stil durchaus vorstellen
zurück nach Deutschland Starkoch Alfons
Schuhbeck muss ins Gefängnis nach
Ansicht eines Münchner Gerichts hat der
Steuern in Millionenhöhe hinterzogen
eigentlich steht Schuhbeck seit
Jahrzehnten für Sterneküche für launige
Auftritte in Koch und Talkshows und für
seine Nähe zur Münchner promiszene aber
auch das ist schuhweg schon 1995 war der
Unternehmer wegen Steuerhinterziehung
verurteilt worden damals noch auf
Bewährung jetzt bekam er mehr als drei
Jahre Petra Neubauer
nun also ist seine wohl größte Angst
wahr geworden Alfons Schuhbeck wird zu
einer Haftstrafe von drei Jahren und
zwei Monaten verurteilt letztlich war
für die Kammer hier ganz entscheidend
das über einen sehr langen Zeitraum mit
einer relativ hohen kriminellen Energie
ein sehr hoher Schaden verursacht worden
ist für das Gericht ist es erwiesen das
Schuhbeck insgesamt 2,3 Millionen Euro
am Finanzamt vorbeigeschleust hat in
seinem Restaurant Orlando hatte dafür
extra ein Computertool installieren
lassen mit dessen Hilfe konnte er
Umsätze aus der Kasse löschen die er
dann Bar entnommen hat auch in seinen
Südtiroler Stuben hat Schuhbeck die
kassenmanipuliert allein hier sind mehr
als tausend Rechnungsnummern
verschwunden die genaue Zahl bleibt
offen
das Schuhbeck viele Vorwürfe eingeräumt
hat bewertet das Gericht positiv doch es
wiegt auch ab
auf der einen Seite das Einräumen das
Übernehmen von Verantwortung auf der
anderen Seite vielleicht der etwas späte
Zeitpunkt und vielleicht auch der
Umstand dass man nicht das eher nicht
wirklich ganz ins Detail gegangen ist
Schuhbecks Verteidiger hatten eine
Bewährungsstrafe gefordert auch mit
Verweis auf dessen Lebensleistung und
Kooperation wir werden jetzt mit unserem
Mandanten in Ruhe über das Urteil
beraten und dann entscheiden wie es
weitergeht
er habe vieles falsch gemacht ändern
könne es leider nicht mehr sagt
Schuhbeck es ist die bittere Einsicht
des einst zur gefeierten starcox
jetzt Fußball Norbert die Frankfurter
jubeln in der Champions League läufts ja
2:1 gegen Olympic Marseille und wieder
eine starke Leistung der Eintracht vor
allem in der ersten Halbzeit ein Sieg im
letzten Gruppenspiel nächsten Dienstag
in Lissabon ja und die Frankfurter
würden sicher ins Achtelfinale einziehen
vom Spiel gezeichnet von den Fans
gefeiert von der eigenen Leistung
besiegt es ist für mich heute ein
außergewöhnlicher Sieg weil ich einfach
weiß was diese diese Spieler hier immer
investieren und bereit sind sich in den
Dienst der Mannschaft zu stellen und das
macht mich wahnsinnig stolz die
Frankfurter präsentieren sich als eine
charakterstarke Einheit setzen bereits
in der dritten Minute den ersten Akzent
im Frankfurter Hexenkessel Kamera und
das 1:0 nach dem Ausgleich durch
Marseille in der 22 Minute organisiert
Götze immer wieder die Angriffe so auch
die Vorlage zum 2:1 von moani mit einem
Kraftakt in der zweiten Halbzeit
verteidigt die Eintracht dieses Ergebnis
und feiert den ersten Heimsieg in der
Champions League
die bereits fürs Achtelfinale
qualifizierten Münchner die haben auch
ihr fünftes Gruppenspiel gewonnen 13:0
stand es am Ende in Barcelona für
überlegene Bayern dank der Tore von
Manet chupa-moting und pavar Barca mit
Robert Lewandowski zum zweiten Mal
nacheinander in der Gruppenphase
ausgeschieden
ja und bayer Leverkusen hat gar keine
Chance mehr aufs Achtelfinale nach dem
2:2 bei Atletico Madrid aber Glück im
Unglück das Spiel schon abgepfiffen der
Schiedsrichter entscheidet aber nach
eingreifendes videoassistenten auf
Elfmeter für Madrid Carrasco tritt an
scheitert am hervorragenden
Bayern-Keeper Radetzky der Nachschuss
von Saul an die Latte und auch ardinio
bringt die Google nicht ins Netz
Leverkusen kann sich jetzt noch für die
Europa League qualifizieren
von der Königsklasse zu den Königsblauen
schalke hat einen neuen Trainer Thomas
Reis wird Nachfolger des glücklosen
Frank Kramer der 49-Jährige war zuvor
Coaching Bochum und soll jetzt die
Knappen 11 aus dem Keller holen Reis ist
bereits der siebte Trainer auf Schalke
in nur zwei Jahren und der hat dann
gleich am Sonntag zu Hause gegen
Freiburg seine erste bewegungsprobe ja
mal sehen schauen wir mal und wir klären
noch schnell die Frage warum abstrakte
Künstler ihre Werke besser signieren
sollten
damit sie richtig rum im Museum hängen
dies hier ist unverkennbar ein Mondrian
klare Linien klare Farben hängt aber
ohne Signatur seit Jahrzehnten falsch
rum so wäre eigentlich richtig glauben
die Macher der Kunstsammlung
Nordrhein-Westfalen sie glauben aber
auch an die Kraft der Gewohnheit und
jetzt bleibt das Bild auf dem Kopf
und das Wetter steht auch irgendwie Kopf
bis 27 Grad warm wird es morgen und das
Ende Oktober mehr gleich von östenthermi
wir empfehlen das heute journal um
viertel vor zehn mit Anne Gellinek danke
für Ihr Interesse alles Gute ihnen und
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter dieser Oktober
könnte der wärmste Oktober seit 1881
werden aber es sind nicht die einzelnen
Monate sondern der Trend der Monate die
immer wärmer werden und so spielt sich
die globale Erhitzung im lokalen wieder
ja und die Wärme das kennen Sie
vielleicht schon aus den letzten Tagen
kommt aus dem Südwesten diese Wetterlage
wiederholt sich und wir bekommen
flächendeckend Temperaturen von 20 bis
25 Grad es ist also nicht nur punktuell
es wird sehr warm ja und in der Nacht da
bildet sich Nebel in der Südhälfte ganz
im Norden ist das Dichter bewölkt mit
etwas Regen viel wird das nicht sein
Temperaturen sinken auf 18 Grad im
Westen Deutschlands und sechs Grad im
Südosten diese Karte könnte auch eine
tagkarte sein so mild ist sie ja und
morgen dann nach nebelauf im Süden viel
Sonnenschein auch nach Westen hin sonst
sind die Wolken eher milchig
durchsichtig die Sonne scheint durch und
27 Grad im Südwesten 25 im Westen und 18
immer noch an der Ostsee und die
nächsten Tage gehen sehr warm weiter bis
26 Grad ein schöner Abend